a New York Times op-ed features an
anonymous resistance leader inside the
White House Brett Kavanaugh hearings
continue with Cory Booker and Kamala
Harris running for president an Alex
Jones invades Capitol Hill and it's
weird I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
every day you think we've reached the
seventh circle of hell you'd be wrong it
could be wrong there they're always
there always further steps down to the
seventh circle we will never reach the
seventh circle of hell there's a story
today actually that aliens had
supposedly landed it but were hovered
over one of president Trump's actual
golf courses in Scotland all I can say
is that that's how this has to end right
that the president Trump is the
president when we actually make first
contact with aliens of another planet
for sure for sure we'll get to all the
news I promise but first we have to talk
about your shaving habit so you want to
be prepped if the aliens do arrive you
want to look good and if you want to
look good you want to smell good you
want to look like a decent human being
you need all the products the Dollar
Shave Club has to offer they have
everything you need to look feel smell
your best they've amazing shower stuff
hair styling products toothbrushes
toothpaste and of course razor and shave
supplies so I am particularly fond of
their amber and lavender body cleanser
it is delightful so is there a black
pepper and sage shampoo oh my goodness
these things just make me smell
wonderful
I mean people at the office could attest
to it but it'll be sexual harassment
we'd have to report them to HR it's that
good okay that's how good the Dollar
Shave Club stuff is that's how I get
ready but you're not me you might have
your own way to get ready you might
shave your whole body to get ready for a
bike race because you're some sort of
weird oh well Dollar Shave Club is good
executive razor and shave butter can
help you do even that you might do your
hair to get ready for your soccer match
because you're one of those weirdos who
play soccer but yes he can do that for
you as well the thing is no matter what
you do to get ready to guess he has
everything you need and right now you
can get ready with an amazing deal on
any one of their starter sets I
recommend that daily essential starter
set because again I love that amber
lavender body cleanser head over to
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben pick your
own GSE starter set for just 5 bucks
after your starter set products ship at
regular price that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen again
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben for the
special deal all right so we begin today
with this anonymous op-ed in The New
York Times which is solely designed to
lead to a full-on mole hunt inside the
White House basically there's an op-ed
in The New York Times is by an anonymous
person the New York Times did not reveal
the name of the person who wrote this
op-ed and the essential contention of
the op-ed is that President Trump is a
crazy person and all the people around
him are restraining him from being crazy
which okay like all right
what do you want from me I mean like
okay I will talk about the ramifications
of this it is titled I am part of the
resistance inside the Trump
administration which of course is titled
just to piss off President Trump I mean
this is almost specifically designed to
make President Trump go full captain
queeg looking for the strawberries it
we're pretty much gonna get the entire
Caine Mutiny
in in real life it'll be just
spectacular here is what the article
says President Trump is facing a test to
his presidency unlike any faced by a
modern American leader sorry I first
have to note the New York Times ran an
editorial note at the top of this piece
and here's what they write they mean
this is just virtue signaling of the
highest order
The Times today is taking the rare step
of publishing not an anonymous op-ed
essay we have done so at the request of
the author a senior official in the
Trump administration whose identity is
known to us and whose job would be
jeopardized by its disclosure we believe
publishing this essay anonymously is the
only way to deliver an important
perspective to our readers we invite you
to submit a question about the essay or
our vetting process here well this does
raise a weird question will the New York
Times reporters now seek to dig into who
actually wrote the you know admits a New
York Times op-ed they could just like
walk down the hall and presumably start
grilling their own editors but that gets
real weird anyway here's what the piece
says President Trump is facing a test to
his presidency unlike any faced by a
modern American leader it's not just
that the special counsel looms large or
that the country is bitterly divided
over mr. Trump's leadership or even that
his party might well lose the house to
an opposition hell-bent on his downfall
the dilemma which he does not fully
grasp is that many of the senior
officials and his own administration are
working diligently from within to
frustrate parts of his agenda and his
worst inclinations
I would know I am one of them I Q an on
I anonymous and one of them to be clear
ours is not the Popular Resistance of
the left we want the administration to
succeed and think that many of its
policies have already made America safer
and more prosperous but we believe our
first duty is to this country and the
president continues to act in a manner
that is detrimental to the help of our
Republic so let me just point out here
that this editorial has already gone off
the rails for a couple of reasons one if
you say that you're part of the
resistance to Trump helping him to do
the right thing you just made sure that
President Trump is going to go on a mole
hunt to oust anyone who is trying to
help him do the right thing from your
own point of view you've ensured that
President Trump is going to go full-on
bring everybody into room prisoner's
dilemma bring in the rubber pipe beat
the crap out of people we're gonna
separate people into rooms and threaten
their families until we find out who is
thwarting the president's will second
those two sentences are in complete
contrast with one another one is that
they want the administration to succeed
and think many of its policies been
great and then there's a sentence that
says that they believe their first
duties to the country and the president
continues to act in a manner detrimental
to the health of our Republic how do you
want the administration to succeed if
you think the president is acting in a
manner detrimental to the health of the
Republic this is basically justifying
everything president Trump ever said
about the deep state but it's actually
just the shallow state it's a bunch of
people working inside his administration
who presumably he appointed who are
working to thwart his will and then
talking about it in the New York Times
the predictable effect of which will be
to lower his approval ratings and
ensured that he has a tougher time with
reelection in 2020 so why exactly would
you say that you're standing up for the
administration if you actually believe
that your job in the administration is
to help the administration succeed make
sure the president Trump doesn't go off
the rails make his policy better for him
when necessary why would you go talk
about it why would you then go and talk
about it that doesn't make any sense at
all I mean it's legitimately a member of
the criminal conspiracy saying you know
what I'm involved in criminality I'm
gonna go talk to the police about how
well I'm attempting to make this
criminal conspiracy work you're talking
to the very people who are attempting to
make sure that Trump exits office so
clearly there's something disingenuous
about this piece from the outset the
piece continues this is why many Trump
appointees have vowed to do what we can
to preserve our democratic institutions
while forwarding mr. Trump's more
misguided impulses until he's out of
office so clearly don't want the
administration to succeed you want him
out of office the root of the problem is
the president's immorality anyone who
works with him knows he is not more to
any discernible first principles that
guide his decision-making which is like
forget about people who work with him
like anybody who watches him for any
prolonged period of time knows this is
true the president considers himself a
pragmatist he's never said that he is a
first principles guy although he was
elected as a Republican the president
shows little affinity for ideals long
espoused by conservatives free minds
free markets free people at best has
invoked these ideals in scripted
settings at worst he's attacked them
outright in addition to his mass
marketing of the notion that the press
is the enemy of the people
president Trump's impulses are generally
anti trade and anti-democratic
don't get me wrong
there are bright spots that the near
ceaseless negative coverage of the
administration fails to capture
effective deregulation historic tax
reform a more robust military and more
but these successes have come despite
not because of the president's
leadership style which is impetuous
adversarial petty and ineffective and it
continues along these lines for
paragraphs and paragraphs with the
result that they say that there's this
this anonymous author inside the Trump
administration says they have a
two-track presidency take foreign policy
in public and private president Trump
shows a preference for autocrats and
dictators such as Vladimir Putin of
Russia and kim jeong-hoon and displays
little genuine appreciation for the ties
that bind us two allied like-minded
nations astute observers have noted
though that the rest of the
administration is operating on another
track 1 more countries like Russia are
called out from meddling and punished
accordingly and we're allies around the
world are engaged as peers rather than
ridiculed as rivals well we know all of
this and they the the piece says this
isn't the work of the so-called deep
state it's the work of the steady state
so yes we are thwarting the president
when we are doing so because we are the
steady state and then this author
suggests that perhaps we should think
about removing the president through the
25th amendment invoking the 25th
amendment
they say that no one wants to
precipitate a constitutional crisis so
instead they're going to steer the
administration in the right direction
until one way or another it is over and
then there is a bunch of references
there a bunch of references to John
McCain and how wonderful John McCain is
and all the rest of it so there are a
bunch of questions to be asked one who
is this person okay it is not a
cabinet-level official it is known with
presidential aspirations it's the
riskiest political move ever
it is not Mike Pence despite how much
the left would love it to be Mike Pence
quietly stabbing president Trump between
the shoulder blades with his trademark
bland smile that is not happening okay
the vice president doing that it is not
nikki Haley who is safely ensconced in
New York far away from the silliness of
the White House this is some second-tier
low-level staffer okay it's a senior
official half the people in the White
House have the title senior official in
the White House this is probably some
senior official in like John Kelly's
team who doesn't like Trump very much
and feels like they might featherbed
their exit and that that's really what
the motive here is the motive here is
that it will be revealed okay within
within a week we'll know who this person
is and this person because it's not
gonna stay secret and this person is
going to come out to great applause from
the left this was a person who was
trying to thwart Trump and Trump fired
him how could from fire
this person who's trying to just make
the administration better and this
person will become not any inside the
White House resistance leader but a
resistance resistance leader that they
will turn into a a full-on and a navarro
character on MSNBC they'll be given a
rich TV contract they'll give him a big
given a rich book contract they will be
given exactly they'll be exonerated
exculpated for all of their terrible
terrible activity in associating with
President Trump this is the maiya culpa
it's a preliminary Maricopa and it
allows the person to exit the
administration amidst glory and huzzah
that's really what this editorial is for
so if you believe for a second that this
editorial is truly designed to either
make the administration better or to
inform the American people you're wrong
first of all we already knew all this
stuff legitimately like everything that
this guy says in the editorial I've been
saying for well for well over a year on
this program since legitimately a couple
of months into the administration I said
this administration is running along two
tracks President Trump says stuff and
then the people around him implement
stuff and those are not the same stuff
there's been very obvious to anyone who
watches at any level when I was on Bill
Maher's show I said this Bill Maher's
and well he always talks about Vladimir
Putin and I said right but then if you
look at the policy of the administration
it is not what he says the policy of the
administration is very harsh on Russia
it's it's quite obvious that this
administration involves the president
saying a lot of stuff being hands-off
delegating power to a lot of folks and
when people say it's a constitutional
crisis to have people around the
president thwarting his will I'm not
even sure what that means it's not as
though they are hiding him in a closet
preventing him from doing things he
wants to do they understand that the
president forgets about things and
doesn't care that much about other
things and that if they just don't put
something on his desk he's unlikely to
ever remember it again so they just
don't put it on his desk like is the
president's will what he wants to do in
the moment or as the president's will
what he cares about over the long haul
because this sort of manipulation does
happen at a much lower level in other
administration's there are people who
are slow walking policy all the time you
donate your job how many times at your
job does your boss say I need something
on my desk now and you think you know
what you'll be better if my boss got
this tomorrow I'm just gonna slow walk
it today is that you thwarting the will
of your company or is that you using
your independent judgment to try and
make the company better because maybe
your boss is about to make a rash
decision as sort of stuff happens all
the time in in your regular job if Trump
doesn't like it he still is plenary
power over the executive branch you can
fire whomever it wants this person will
be uncovered and fired nonetheless the
White House is is going to be torn apart
by the chaos of now attempting to of
attempting to uncover who exactly the
mole is and president Trump reacts as
his apt to do in pretty much the worst
possible way to this particular op-ed
and just as I'm sure the op-ed author
wanted him to react which is by acting
off the rails and that's sort of the
entire point of what the author was
trying to do here we'll talk about that
in just a second first let's talk about
the look of your home so you look around
your home and it just feels shabby
you're not sure why well believe it or
not it might be the window coverings in
fact you probably haven't thought about
the window coverings for a long time
they even for me when I do construction
on my house
I don't think about the window coverings
and then as soon as they're replaced
over a blinds calm I think wow that made
a huge difference a huge difference well
go over to blinds calm and make your
house look awesome today
blinds calm makes it really really easy
for you to change the window coverings
it means that you're not going to have
to spend the normos amounts of time and
money buying blinds instead if you're
not sure where to start or what you want
with blinds calm you get a free online
design consultation you send them
pictures of your house they send back
custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture in specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure everything looks as good in
person as it does online every order
gets free shipping here's the best part
if you miss measure you pick the wrong
color you screw up blinds.com makes it
right for you for free right they will
remake your blinds for free if you screw
it up they've really made it easy for a
limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds comm when you use promo code Ben
that's blinds.com promo code Ben for 20%
off everything for wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more blinds
calm promo code Ben rules and
restrictions do apply okay so the
President of the United States reacts as
you would expect him to react to an
op-ed from inside his administration the
killers in the house ah calling from
upstairs on the phone oh my god
okay so president Trump reacts in
typical trumpian fashion he is in front
of a crowd of sheriffs who are some of
his closest allies because he's very Pro
law enforcement and here's President
Trump ripping into the failing New York
Times yeah
the New York Times and
and all of these phony media outlets
will be out of business folks they'll be
out of business because there'll be
nothing to write and there'll be nothing
of interest so if the failing New York
Times has an anonymous editorial can you
believe it anonymous meaning gutless a
gutless editorial we're doing a great
job okay and the truth is he's not wrong
about being gutless like if the person
actually wants to take a stand against
the administration publicly quit quit
and talk about how terrible it was or
alternatively if you actually want to
work inside the administration and make
it a better place shut your face why are
you going to the New York Times to brag
about how you anonymously are helping
the administration from the inside
except to provide yourself cover later
this is very obviously self-interested
do you really think anybody at the New
York Times would have printed an
anonymous op-ed from somebody inside the
Obama administration making the same
claims highly highly highly doubtful
because prints economist op eds is kind
of frowned upon it's kinda frowned upon
for pretty good reason which is that
there's no way to vet the claims of the
person who's actually making those
claims but we don't know who the senior
official is it could be some low-level
person who's met from once there are
hundreds of people working in the White
House hundreds of them so that is quite
plausible but President Trump then goes
to Twitter and he decides that he is
going to lose it so President Trump had
a couple of tweets he tweeted out does
the so-called senior administration
official really exist or is it just the
failing New York Times with another
phony source if the gutless anonymous
person does indeed exist The Times must
for national security purposes turned
him or her over to government at once so
no no times I'm gonna do that that's not
a thing yeah the press doesn't have to
turn people over to the federal
government for writing them op-ed that
rips on the administration that's not an
actual thing and then the president had
one more tweak all caps treason question
mark so I guess now we're going to
execute this person we're gonna find
them they're like the proscribed penalty
in the Constitution for treason is death
so presumably we will find this person
take them out back and trumple them get
he'll take his tie off and then he will
strangle him with with the oversized red
tie it'll be quite amusing but here's
the problem with President Trump's
response basically the op eds has the
president's accredited
and it is it's a terrible stupid
backwards outrageously dumb op-ed but
the central contention is President
Trump is a crazy man and we have to
restrain him and president Trump's
responses I'm not crazy
you're crazy you're you're so crazy I'm
gonna take your head off I'm gonna take
care I want to rip it off your neck and
then I'm going to defecate down your
throat oh that's what I'm gonna do to
you I am going to rip your legs off and
beat you to death with them you're
calling me crazy and out of control how
dare you and believe about unreal mr.
president if you wanted to react in you
know the fashion that is most likely to
put this to bed what you would say is ah
there they are talking again of course
the New York Times gonna print this sort
of stuff no not they should turn it over
this bastard me so I can blow a hole in
and with this drill
I'll just take this this I have a
screwdriver right here I was stabbed in
the face 100 times I will shoot him on
Fifth Avenue and I lose no support at
this point you have to laugh so you
don't cry because it is it is pretty
wild stuff but it is also true that this
op-ed does no good it is actually deeply
counterproductive because all it does in
the end is Drive president Trump to
throw out anyone who may be actually
trying to curb those worst excesses and
now we get to spend months trying to
trying to you know drill down on how it
is drill down on exactly how it is that
this this happened in the first place
okay meanwhile speaking of stupidity
awfulness counterproductive nonsense we
need to stop these judicial hearings
these judicial hearings are a waste of
time
these Senate Judiciary Committee
hearings are just a place for
prospective presidential candidates to
grandstand now Brett Kavanaugh is doing
you know a fine job at what his job is
here in these judicial hearings which is
to obfuscate how he feels on every
particular issue the way this works
thanks to Ruth Bader Ginsburg is that
Ruth Bader Ginsburg once she was
questioned about specific cases she said
I'm not going to answer any questions
about prospective cases or cases in the
past I'm gonna sit here and look at you
weird and that was basically how every
that's now how we do judicial hearings
they people ask questions that are
designed to elicit a response from the
cheering throng on either side of the
aisle and then the judge sits there and
the judge basically stares weirdly at
them well that's basically what happened
yesterday and Cavanaugh's Pro added
I mean here's Cavanaugh for example
giving an answer on Roe versus Wade this
is clip 11
here's Cavanaugh answering on Roe versus
Wade giving about the vaguest answer you
could possibly give senator I said that
it's settled as a precedent of the
Supreme Court entitled the respect under
principles of starry decisis and I
understand your point of view on that
Center and I understand how passionate
and how deeply people feel about this
issue I understand the importance of the
issue I understand the the importance
that people attached to the roe v-- wade
decision to the Planned Parenthood
versus Casey decision okay that that's a
big way of saying nothing
roni says that is precedent based on
precedent right and the Supreme Court is
not bound by precedent so what are you
gonna do on the case the answer is we
have no idea that's not stopping the New
York Times from printing leaked
Cavanaugh documents about abortion and
affirmative action and they're calling
it a bombshell a bombshell is it really
a bombshell no of course it's not a
bombshell of course it's not a bombshell
judge Kavanaugh when he was working for
the Bush administration was considering
a draft opinion piece that supporters of
one of mr. Bush's Conservatives appeals
to court nominees hope they could
persuade anti-abortion women to submit
under their names it stated it is widely
accepted by legal scholars across the
board that roe v wade and his progeny
are the settled law of the land and
Cavanaugh proposed deleting that line
writing I'm not sure that all legal
scholars refer to Roe is the settled law
of the land at the Supreme Court level
since the court can always overrule its
precedent and three current justices on
the court would do so that doesn't mean
he would do so that is an apt and
accurate description of the state of the
law the Supreme Court can overrule
anything when people say settled law of
the land what they really mean is we
don't want people to reopen it and it's
an inaccurate description there's no
such thing as the settled law in the lay
of the land in Supreme Court
jurisprudence
sorry decisis does not always apply
precedent does not always apply if it
did then Plessy vs. Ferguson would still
be on the books and people would still
be segregating bus cars at the behest of
the state so that's not a thing but
again Brett Kavanaugh is being run
through the ringer specifically for
political purposes here for example is
is Kavanaugh being asked about
presidential pardons again he's not
gonna answer this question but we're
gonna pretend like these hearings matter
the question of self pardons is
something I have never analyzed it's a
question that I have not written about
it's a question therefore that's a
hypothetical question that I can't begin
with knots or in this context as a
sitting judge and as a nominee to the
Supreme other half of that is okay so
again he's got no answer on that cuz he
doesn't have to answer any of that this
entire hearing is just designed for
Democrats to grandstand for 2020 they
are basically just standing there
shouting and just shouting that's it
right there they're my son when he wakes
up in the morning and he screams from
his from his crib Dada come get me okay
this is these are the Democrats it pay
attention to me attention now please
ah dad I just saved you like 35 hours of
watching Senate Judiciary Committee
committee hearings that's all Senate
Democrats are doing and right now the
two who are best at it are Kamala Harris
who is being taken seriously and Cory
Booker who is a parody of a parody Cory
Booker is a muppet he's a human Muppet
and all he does is a human Muppet is
just make weird faces at people and I
mean he literally called himself
Spartacus in a hearing this morning I am
not kidding you Cory fricking Booker
just called himself Spartacus at a
hearing this morning I'll have to
explain why he called himself Spartacus
any hearing this morning because he
really is astonishing and hilarious and
also he doesn't understand how Spartacus
work like Spartacus ended up crucified
so there's that but it's all good times
for Cory Booker and the Senate Judiciary
Committee we'll talk about all that in
just a second first let's talk about the
fact that time is moving slowly that
means you're checking your watch more
often when you check your watch
shouldn't you have something nice like
this shouldn't you have a watch that you
like looking at because it's classy and
it's simple and it's minimalist and it
looks nice well that is where movement
comes in we've talked about movement
before on the program obviously you know
there are these two college dropouts
they started their own watch company and
the company has grown like crazy they've
now sold 2 million watches in 160 plus
countries and they continue to
revolutionize fashion in the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank movement
has come pretty far in the past year
they've not only introduced a bunch of
new watch collections for men and women
they've also expanded to sunglasses
fashion for bracelets for her I've got
the
sunglasses my wife has the sunglasses
too they have all these great options
and they as I say they're really durable
so this makes a difference to young
parents like me because my kids will
grab my watch and just truck them
against the wall movement washes stand
up to the beating movement watches are
about looking good keeping it simple
they don't tell you how many steps
you've taken they don't blow up your
wrist with text messages instead they
just tell you the time in the classiest
way movement watches start at ninety
five bucks at a department store
they're like four hundred five hundred
bucks they cut out the middleman right
now get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to MVM
t-dot-com slash Shapiro
that's MVM t-dot-com slash Shapiro see
why the movement keeps growing MVM t.com
slash Shapiro join the movement go check
it out right now okay so Cory Booker as
I say he calls himself Spartacus why
because he decided today and who's gonna
violate the rules of the Senate by
simply releasing a bunch of classified
documents now the way this works is that
there are a bunch of documents that are
shown to the various senators on the
Judiciary Committee that are held
closely by executive privilege if you're
working for the Bush administration the
Bush administration has the right to say
that the legislative branch does not get
to see things because that is executive
privilege it is pro the executive is not
subject to the dictates of the
legislature so the legislature can't
just say we want every document
everything Bush ever said to all of his
all of the advocates we want all of that
in front of us now that's not a thing in
constitutional jurisprudence so there's
basically a deal that was made with the
Senate Judiciary Committee which is they
get to see all these Cavanaugh documents
on the condition that they are not asked
about publicly so so it can decide the
votes of the people on the committee but
it is not meant to it is not meant to
undercut the executive power right so
Cory Booker being a grandstanding idiot
he decides you know what is a great idea
I'm just gonna release these documents
I'm just gonna come out and release
these documents I'm gonna violate Senate
rules I'm just gonna state it upfront
and then if you want to if you want to
expel me from the Center for violation
of Senate rules if you want to please if
you want to expel me from the Senate if
you want to expel me then do it I'm just
like Spartacus except I'm begging you to
crucify me see the thing about Spartacus
is that he didn't actually want to be
identified as Spartacus because then
they would kill him which is why
everyone identified as Spartacus but
Cory Booker doesn't know anything
because he's stupid
so instead he says that he has led
Spartacus in basically begging to be
crucified please please expel me points
to it because if you do it maybe I can
run for president cuz I'll show how much
Republicans hate me and then I can make
weird googly eyes and I can do it weird
jazz fingers it'll be all weird but I'll
be President cuz weird
so here's cory booker being all weird i
will say that i did willingly violate
the chairs rule on the committee
confidential process i take full
responsibility for violating that sir
and i violated because i sincerely
believe that the public deserves to know
this nominees a record in this
particular case his record on issues of
race and the law and and i could not
understand and i violated this rule
knowingly why why these issues should be
withheld from the public now I
appreciate the comments of my colleagues
this is about the closest I'll probably
ever have in my life to an I am
Spartacus moment oh my god this guy's
like the Nick Cage of the Senate just
every every scene that he acts in yeah
hey what what are you what yeah have you
ever seen chewing of the scenery like
this here's the thing Kamala Harris is
good at playing the prosecutor on TV and
she's actually good at this Cory Booker
is just he's the worst kid in her high
school drama class he liked the kid who
watched who at one point watched movies
in like the 1980s and thought that
Arnold Schwarzenegger his performance in
Kindergarten Cop was the apotheosis of
good acting I was like you know what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna shout a lot
whoo-hoo things that William Shatner is
a great actor and he's like William
Shatner everything he says his God every
single thing
so there's cory booker doing that and
then cory booker he's just he's just the
worst
the knowingly violating the rules like
he's been he says i knowingly violated
the rose am giving you every motivation
you can for its please i need the
attention no one's paying attention to
me pat you Debbie please there's cory
booker again pay attention to him people
pay attention he needs your attention he
wants your attention why don't you love
him why do you pay attention you can't
just ignore me it's gonna boil a rabbit
there's cory booker - senator Cornyn
actually made a very good
I knowingly violated the rules that were
put for and I'm told that the committee
confidential rules have knowing
confident consequences and so sir I come
from a long line as all of us do as
Americans and understand what but that
kind of civil disobedience is and I
understand the consequences so I am
right now before your before your
process is finished
I'm going to release the email about
racial profiling and I understand that
that the penalty comes with potential
I'll sting from the Senate please ask me
please please show the Democrats that
I'm really committed to the show all the
base that I'm really committed to this
may Elsa me from make me a martyr martyr
me martyr me it's like oh my god he's
just terrible at this so it actually
makes you appreciate Kamala Harris who
is better at this right I mean at least
if you're gonna watch this sort of thing
you hope that they're pretty good at it
Kamala Harris is better at it or at
least she's being taken more seriously
by the media she's decided that she is
now going to go after Brett Kavanaugh
based on what based on like the
stupidest crap you've ever heard so
here's Kamala Harris completely getting
wrong the law about abortion well done
Kamala can you think of any laws that
give government the power to make
decisions about the male body I'm happy
to answer her more specific question but
male versus female there are medical
procedures I mean the government that
the government has the power to make a
decision about a man's body I'm not a
I'm not a thinking of any right now
senator okay what she's trying to go for
it is when it come I mean she's just
obviously phrasing this in the dumbest
possible way so that it looks as though
the law is unequal when it comes to
abortion because all we're talking about
is a female body whereas there are no
restrictions on what a male can do to
his own body except when we actually do
have laws against suicide like we can
actually put you in jail for not jail
but we can we can actually forcibly you
know incarcerated not and what's the
word I'm looking for we can actually we
can put you on a psychiatric hold for 48
hours if you're suicidal so if you are
if you are a man we can call the cops
you and do that also we do have laws on
the books that allow with male bodies to
be harmed they're actually called
pro-abortion laws those pro bortion laws
allow male bodies to be harmed because
they're inside female bodies so there's
that there's Kamala Harris grandstanding
I do love Brett Kavanaugh just looking
blankly at her like what are you what
are you saying no say who say what what
in the world and then this is the best
one so Kamala Harris has decided she's
got the goods what are the goods
she thinks that Brett Cavanaugh has
talked to some worm from the firm of
Kassovitz Casa what's his firm that is
used by the President of the United
States with regard to his defense and so
she asked Brett Kavanaugh if he's ever
had a conversation with anyone who
worked for Casa watts which is a firm
that legitimately has hundreds and
hundreds of lawyers about the Muller
investigation the implication being that
Brett Kavanaugh somehow talked to
Trump's lawyers about how he would
handle the Muller investigation with
which he is not involved in any way but
she's got she's going to suggest the
reason Trump is picking Cavanaugh is
because Cavanaugh is somehow going to
allow Trump to escape them all our
investigation this was ranking real high
unsorted left his pornography list
yesterday so this is this one is running
up the pornography list people were
really just self-flagellating over it
really enjoying themselves here was
Kamala Harris making a fool of herself
men Michael a Vinod he got involved in
Michael haven't any basically shredded
her so it's pretty funny Kassovitz
Benson and Torres which is the law firm
founded by Mark Casa wits who is
president Trump's personal lawyer are
you have you had any conversation about
robert muller or his investigation with
anyone at that firm yes or no well is
there a person you're talking I'm asking
you a very direct question yes or no
yeah I need to know the I'm not sure I
know everyone who works at that law firm
I don't think you need to I think you
need to know who you talked with who'd
you talk to okay and then it continued
like this for like seven and a half
minutes okay casis Benson has 266
attorneys do you think that he's got
he's got he's racking his brains right
now going who have I talked to you did
they once work at Kassovitz
I don't want to perjure myself by saying
I've never talked to anybody about the
Muller invent like I don't remember
every
conversation I've ever had about the
Muller investigation I've talked to
thousands of people it turns out about
the Muller investigation but I'm not
sure who worked for Casa woods at the
time but this was supposed to be you
know the great the great uncovering of
course there's nothing there Michael
avenatti basically said this is a big
mistake
you know prosecutors are not supposed to
ask questions to which they don't
already know the answers so if it turns
out that Kamala Harris has nothing here
then she was just grandstanding and
speaking of grandstanding you just heard
Colonel Cory Booker talking about how he
was going to uncover all of the evils of
Brett Kavanaugh by revealing all this
classified information it turns out that
Cory Booker he played himself Cory
Booker played himself congratulations he
played himself Cory Booker the the
emails what do they show there's a probe
there there's an email titled racial
profiling and then it turns out that in
these emails titled racial profiling
Brett Kavanaugh openly says that we are
not going to allow people to use race or
national origin in airport screening and
law enforcement generally in the
immediate aftermath of 9/11 he says my
own view is that as required by the
traditional equal protection standards
who must at least consider how to
construct a race-neutral system I can
imagine such a system that could be
effective perhaps even more effective
than the one based on racial
classifications this sort of system
would require airlines and governmental
authorities to obtain more personal
information from the flying public and
there are some resistance that within
the group on the grounds that would be
too burdensome invasive privacy and so
forth the people who favor some use of
race or national origin obviously do not
need to grapple with the interim
questions but the people who generally
favor effective security measures that
are race neutral in fact do need to
grapple and grapple now with the interim
question of what to do before it truly
an effective and comprehensive
race-neutral system is developed and
implemented so in other words Cory
Booker wanted to show how Cavanaugh was
a racist and instead showed how
Cavanaugh was not in fact a racist so
well done Cory Booker you complete and
utter douchebag so in just one second we
will get to more from the Senate
Judiciary hearing will also get to other
hearings that are happening on the hill
yesterday which were similarly bizarre
because we live in a parallel universe
in which nothing makes sense anymore but
first let's talk about your coffee if
you've ever found yourself wincing at
the weak taste of coffee for when those
left-leaning corporate brands you
probably thought I wish they spent less
time on that meaningless biased training
who can use their bathroom and more time
on making good coffee well this is why
you need black rifle coffee it is
first-rate coffee I've tried it myself
it is excellent coffee we have it here
at the office founded by former Special
Ops vets black rifle delivers the best
roasts to order coffee right to your
door and by the way the guys who run it
they're awesome this guarantees you are
getting fresh premium coffee with every
order and black rifle has a coffee club
that makes things easy no lines no
running out just great coffee shipped
right to your door every month hassle
free and when you join their coffee club
you'll receive discounts and offers not
available to other customers not only
does black rifle make awesome awesome
coffee they also give a portion of their
sales to veterans and first responder
causes as well when you choose black
rifle you are choosing a company that
supports our vets loves conserves coffee
and culture to people who love America
visit black rifle coffee comm slash men
get 15% off your order right now that's
black rifle coffee calm select none
these guys are hardcore and so is their
coffee it's awesome black rifle coffee
calm slash pen for 15% off again black
rifle coffee calm slash burn so just
spectacular performance by all the
members of the left in this judicial
hearing but that wasn't the only hearing
where things were going wildly wrong in
the Senate they were also going wildly
wrong in the Senate at Tech hearing so
yesterday there is a Senate committee
hearing with Facebook and Twitter and
the leadership of those companies
talking about the level of social media
censorship that occurs on a regular
basis we'll talk about that in just a
second but first you're actually gonna
have to sign off a Facebook so go over
to daily wired I'll come right now and
subscribe $9.99 a month means that you
get the rest of the show live the rustic
Levens show live the rest of Noel's show
live Plus you also get to be part of our
mailbag which we are doing tomorrow so
you'll want to check that out also for
$99 a year in abeyance of the instead of
the $9.99 a month subscription you get a
cheaper plus you get the leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr when you spend $99 a
year get the annual because it's better
and because you are helping us out so
please check that out as well also make
sure you subscribe over at YouTube or
iTunes because that will ensure that you
get our Sundays special this week it is
christina hoff sommers
and a fascinating conversation about me
too and everything else she's she's
broken the glass ceiling on our Sunday
special by the way she is the first
female that we've had on the sunday
special that was not in fact a conscious
decision I don't sit here going I will
not allow a female here until christina
hoff sommers enters
it's just hard to find
of women who are based on the west coast
but we are hoping to have more females
in the very near future including steven
crowder well sorry wouldn't want to
actually discuss steven Crowder's gender
but we'll talk about all that later go
check us out right now we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so big tech hearings on the hill
yesterday
and things got weird even before the
tech hearings start Alex Jones arrives
that's not if you were if you saw him
holding his phone that was not trans
porn on his phone stop thinking that it
was not it was not but he arrives and he
had costs Marco Rubio now Rubio is one
of the more polished politicians on the
hill obviously Rubio happens to be a
nice guy I know senator Rubio Alex Jones
is not a nice guy Alex Jones the crazy
person who says crazy things and then he
just sort of randomly takes off his
shirt and starts yelling about Satan but
Satan just goes wild oh that's oh he
brings that brand to the halls of the
Senate and he accosts Marco Rubio about
the fact that he's been banned from
social media now as I say I oppose Alex
Jones ban from social media unless
there's an articulable standard an
articulable standard of why he was ban
was he banned because he threatens
violence was he ban because he promotes
libelous conspiracy theories like
legally libelous conspiracy theorists
why exactly was he banned if it's just
because you don't like him that's not a
good reason so I had sympathy for the
argument that all these social media
companies that say he was engaged in
hate speech so ban him that's a problem
because hate speech has no actual
definition with any sort of
distinguishing principle involves
there's no limiting principle to hate
speech that said Alex Jones arrives and
he starts harassment Marco Rubio about
this why he's not going to harassing the
Democrats about this I'm not really sure
but he goes India wrasses Marco Rubio
and things go wildly wrong tens of
millions of views the Rush Limbaugh he
knows who went forward is playing this
joke over here that's why if any
platform didn't work but I don't
okay so first of all the first rule of
engaging with trolls is don't engage
with trolls because there's really no
way that it works out well although I
will say that I like if there would be a
physical altercation between Alex Jones
and Marco Rubio and Marco Rubio who's
considered bata cuck number one by the
Alex Jones crowd were to knock
Alex Jones and his mega steroids coffee
crop of garbage if you were to knock my
eye I'm not in favor of physical
violence I think law enforcement is
useful we live in a civilized society
for a reason but if they were to get in
a physical altercation and Marco Rubio
we're to undercut Alex Jones the entire
brand by knocking out Alex Jones I I
would laugh a little and when I say a
little I mean I would never stop
laughing I would miss the show the next
day because the laughter would be would
be so great so that's out when Marco
Rubio then did an interview and what she
said and I know you guys have to cover
it but you guys give these crazy people
way too much attention we're making
crazy people superstars we're gonna get
crazier people and of course Rubio is
right all the coverage on Alex Jones is
designed for that it is also also true
that the presidents of the United States
happens to be one of the people giving
Alex Jones inordinate attention hey Alex
Jones has been known as a crazy person
for many many many years the President
of the United States decided that he was
a friendly and therefore he sort of
legitimized him in any case these the
let's talk a little bit more about these
tech hearings so these tech hearings
they they were they were demonstrative
of the fact that these social media
companies really have no clue as to what
their actual goal is is their goal to
quote unquote better the public
discourse because if their goal is to
better the public discourse then they
need to be held accountable for their
firm for all the material that appears
on their pages over at Daily wire we can
be sued for for libel we can be sued for
copyright violation we can be sued for a
variety of causes because we are a
private company that is engaged in the
business of editorial oversight if you
are if you are basically just a platform
and you're not involved in editorial
over say like reddit or 4chan or
presumably Facebook then you can't be
sued on the same grounds so an article
that we could be sued for if we post it
on Facebook Facebook could not be sued
for but if Facebook is policing
everything and deciding what comes down
and what stays up well now they look a
lot more like The Daily wire than they
look like the phone line then they look
like just AT&T they now look like a
publisher so if you're a publisher and
not a platform then you have to be held
to the same standard and we have to have
an articulable standard so that we know
exactly what's going on at your company
and that was made pretty clear when
representative Mark Wayne read a read
tweets to the I guess his name is Mark
Wayne Moen hey he read tweets too
the Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey about about
race from Sarah Zhang you member sarahs
young who's now on the New York Times
editorial board because only certain
types of racism are okay here is a
representative Mullin grilling Dorsey on
white is that Sarah Jong is still on the
platform but other people have been
banned for similarly racist talk let me
read what what miss Jang wrote hash tag
cancel white people white people marking
up the internet with their opinions like
dogs pissing on fire hydrants are white
people genetically predisposed to burn
faster in the Sun that's logically being
only fit to live underground by
graveling goblins oh man it's kind of
sick how much I enjoy or how much
jewelry I get out of being cruel to old
white man and you can sort of see the
the twitter CEO in the cutaway shot you
can see him feeling pretty uncomfortable
he should feel pretty uncomfortable
because it's it's ridiculous frankly
that Twitter in and all of these social
media companies I run the way they are
where they pretend that their policing
things when they really are only
policing one side and that side is
really perceived to be sort of the
pro-trump side it meanwhile speaking of
stupidity Nike has now released its new
ad involving Colin Kaepernick it's
designed to obviously draw all sorts of
media scrutiny so we'll give them what
they want here here is the Nike ad it's
a voiceover from a Colin Kaepernick who
obviously is not in uniform since he
doesn't play football anymore
he stands around and talks about cops
being bad from his multi-million dollar
mansion presumably and they juxtapose
Colin Kaepernick's heroism with like
actual heroes in sports I mean they they
actually show video are like small kids
who have who have genetic conditions
trying to play sports and they're
comparing that to Colin Kaepernick whose
great sacrifice was kneeling after he'd
already become a useless backup
quarterback for the San Francisco 49ers
if you're born a refugee don't let it
stop you from playing sucker
[Music]
at age 16
don't become the best basketball player
on the planet be bigger than basketball
believe in something even if it means
sacrificing everything when they talk
about the greatest team in the history
of sport make sure is your team if you
have only one hand
don't just watch football play at the
highest level
and here a girl from Compton don't just
become a tennis player become the
greatest athlete ever you have to
sacrifice everything when Tollan
Kaepernick did by being signed to a
multi-million dollar contract and being
treated as a civil rights hero despite
having lived in a Tony white suburb for
most of his upbringing and then playing
for millions of dollars badly so thank
you for that Nike it really really just
done what's amazing about this is all of
these success stories or at least a huge
number of these success stories that are
being shown here are American success
stories Venus Williams in Serena
Williams are American success stories
the u.s. women's soccer team is an
American success story these are stories
that happen in America because America's
a great country but we are going to be
presented with this theme by a
corporation attempting to make money in
America off American citizens that
really America is a place that presents
nothing but endless obstacles and
challenges and you have to be a self
sacrificial character like Colin
Kaepernick to truly sacrifice everything
whole thing's ridiculous and insulting
but I guess if Nike thinks they can make
money off it more power to them if they
lose some sneaker sales off of it I
would not be heartbroken over any of
that okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like I've been rewatching
roam on HBO it's early HBO which means
early HBO is even more
poorni than sort of later HBO yeah you
can see this with Game of Thrones where
Game of Thrones started in every two
scenes there was some graphic sex scene
because it was like we know or pay cable
if you're if you want to watch pay cable
at least you'll get some boobies that
that's really how the programming goes
at HBO so there's some of that in Rome
if you can ignore all of that the series
is actually really really good here is
here's some of the preview for for Rome
which is worth three watching if you in
especially now you can get on like
Amazon Prime and that means that if you
are so if you're apt to do is I am and
you just fast-forward right through
those scenes and get to the good stuff
the actual politics
[Applause]
they claim proconsul Gaius Julius Caesar
you've entered the city under arms the
gods know my intentions of peace what
you do by the spirits of My Ancestors I
curse season
so it's good it's really well done it's
entertaining it's got some of the best
characters in the one character named
Titus Pullo is one of the better
characters in TV history and kind of TV
aficionados are big fans so check it out
it's available via HBO via Amazon Prime
on HBO or if you're an HBO subscriber so
that's worth watching okay time for some
things that I hate so now every
corporation feels the necessity to get
involved in politics at Levis is now
pledging more than a million dollars to
gun control organizations in an effort
to curb the gun violence and the quote
vary communities where we live and work
one of the reasons why this is happening
is because Nielsen numbers show that
there are large numbers of people on the
lefts want their corporations to be
socially conscious people on the right
we basically just go and buy what we
want and most people buy what they want
but there are a lot of people on the
left we're like well I'm not gonna buy
those jeans unless I feel good about it
it's conspicuous consumption there are
actual studies that show that people
only buy Priuses because they look
strange really if you go up to San
Francisco there's a study it's probably
five years ago
there's the study and what it showed was
that the toyota prius which looks like a
weird bubble it's very ugly car and the
honda hybrid civic which were which
looks exactly like a normal car but gets
exactly the same kind of electric gas
mileage as a Toyota Prius
the hybrid Civic did not sell at all the
Prius sold a lot why because the real
reason people were buying a Prius was
not because it was energy-efficient
because they didn't actually care what
it did they just wanted to signal to all
of their friends they cared about the
environment it's like slapping a bumper
sticker on your car well it's the same
thing now with corporate brands so
you're gonna see more and more of this
preening from these various companies
and then if the companies don't preen
then they are going to be considered
just awful terrible you know how dare
they not kowtow to the social justice
warriors everything is going to get more
political not less political it's gonna
get uglier before before it gets better
okay other things that I hate so the
President of the United States made some
comments about the the current
controversy in the Catholic Church and
it is these comments are just foolish
you made these comments to the Daily
Caller
I do have audio of it okay so here's
what he said he said it's so sad to
watch to me it's one of the saddest
stories because I respect so much the
Catholic Church and to me it's a very
sad story which is correct but then he
says that he was surprised
Cardinal McCarrick and then he was asked
about the Pope and he said the Pope is
handling the crisis the best anyone can
handle it the Pope is handling I get the
best set anyone can handle it how is he
going to handle it okay well no the Pope
is not actually it's funny because you
remember that Trump has attacked the
Pope in the past right he actually went
to war with the Pope over illegal
immigration but when it comes to child
molestation he's not willing to make a
couple of comments about the Pope that
seems sort of strange to me I don't
understand why exactly he would not you
know why he would not be calling for
more from the Pope except that he just
doesn't want that controversy if you're
I understand not wanting the controversy
but if you're going to engage with every
political controversy Under the Sun it
seems to me this would be a good place
to put a little bit of weight okay final
thing that I hate and then we'll do a
quick Psalm for a little bit of uplift
so beta O'Rourke who is not in fact
Hispanic is a is a Texas senatorial
candidate he's running against Ted Cruz
and he's being upheld by the media as
some sort of wunderkind he is he's going
to bring decency and grace back to the
national stage he's like white Barack
Obama he actually is kept more like
white young John Kerry yeah if you watch
him he just he looks more like John
Kerry his mannerisms are more like John
Kerry he doesn't have the Boston accent
otherwise he resembles John Kerry in a
lot of ways he was on Ellen because this
is what we do now you know Ellen she's a
non-partisan guys stop it
she's nonpartisan she just wants humor
she just wants everybody to get along
which is why she's gonna host a bunch of
Republicans next thing you know except
she never will
she's gonna host better all right so
here's better o'rourke talking about the
national anthem protest and of course
coming down on the side of people who
protest the national anthem if this guy
wins in Texas men the Republicans are in
serious trouble
but it's hard to think of a major or
important or significant change that
we've made as a country that wasn't
painful that didn't require these these
difficult conversations these unguarded
moments with one another that ultimately
produce change and progress in the right
direction
he is so exciting I understand what all
the buzz is about oh the excitement but
they say well we'll have these
conversations and they'll generate
change in the right direction no they
won't they won't I'm sorry people who
aren't kneeling for the national anthem
are generally not interested in a
conversation which is why they are
kneeling for the national anthem if they
wanted to have an intelligent
conversation about police regulations
and police implementation of rules we
could have that
conversation in an intelligent way or
theoretically we could just kneel for
the anthem and pretend the entire
country is in favor of police
malfeasance okay time for a quick song
so we have been going through a psalm a
week we're up to Psalm number eight for
the director of music Lord O Lord how
majestic is your name in all the earth
you set your glory in the heavens
through the praise of children and
infants you have established a
stronghold against your enemies to
silence the foe and the Avenger and this
is the part that's that's there are a
couple of what we call sukham in Judaism
in Hebrew which means verses when I
consider your heavens the work of your
fingers the moon and the stars which we
have set in place what is mankind that
you are mindful of them human beings
that you care for them you've made them
a little lower than the angels and
crowned them with honor and glory you
have made them rulers over the works of
your hands and you put everything under
their feet this is why when people say
that judeo-christian religion is all
about kind of crushing mankind in the
face of God that's really not what you
do Christian religion is about at all
right the psalms glorify man they say
that God made us just a little bit lower
than the angels which comes with a
tremendous responsibility the creator of
heaven and earth the force that stands
behind the logic of the universe that
force made you and that force expect
something of you God expects something
of you right he made us a little lower
than the Angels and in some ways he in
our in our creative capacity
he made us higher the Angels because the
Angels don't create right the angels are
just emissaries when God suggests that
we are a little lower than the angels
and that we've been crowned with glory
and honor and has made us rulers over
the works right that comes with a
responsibility it's not just about I
think in Western civilization we've had
too much on the side of man is glorious
and therefore he should feel free to do
whatever he wants and in guilt cultures
shame cultures there's a difference I
think that we are a guilt culture I
think shame cultures have basically said
that man is is mud and can be ground
under people's feet for the sake of the
collective we're somewhere in between
right well we say is that man is capable
being an angel a man is capable of being
a worm but we have to make that decision
and God has expectations of us one of
the more beautiful of all the Psalms
Psalm number eight God how majestic is
your name in all the earth already we
will be back here tomorrow with more of
the absurdities of our daily politics
plus the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing